have a kind of crazy stat
um did you know that 40 of women that
have had abortions have already had two
or more um
that's that's in the us and the uk
very crazy stuff so what's that three
altogether
two or more yeah
and they don't track the sixty percent
like how would they know what sixty
percent have we're going to have them in
the future
so it's probably higher yeah
i've had this conversation with with
family i've had this conversation with
friends i think that
getting
for for a woman getting pregnant is a
choice and sometimes they'll uh you know
society will have you think that it's an
accident or it can happen by accident
not in 2022. maybe
you know maybe a hundred years ago it
could you know you it might happen by
accident you know i mean you never know
but in 2022 it's a choice it's a choice
that you make it's a conscious choice
so do you guys think abortion is murder
in some cases yeah
yeah oh you you're looking at i don't
know is that he's the one that's talking
about two is fine how about how far
between i said i have an equation like
say like the morning after pill
no
abortion is murder
yeah
oh you do okay yeah
and also may i just quickly um state
something abortion after
12 weeks especially i think it's murder
100 because that baby is formed now
and in some cases you can actually tell
the gender at 12 14 weeks my son uh i
had a scan
um he was 14 we said we could actually
tell he was a boy so if you're killing a
fetus that 14 you're killing a human
but i think i think the difficult thing
here is
there was a point in time where we
didn't have scans
right so we're at the point right now
where a scan can detect a heartbeat at
around six weeks and so forth
you know who's to say that you know in a
couple years time that that the the
scan's not going to be even more
advanced then you're not going to be
able to detect life even even before
that
um and i think even if you look at it
like the dna code is it's pretty it
happens almost immediately it does um
and so i definitely i i definitely side
with it being being a murderer to be
honest what do you think of people who
say that it's
not murder and it's just a
a collection of cells and it's a fetus
and it doesn't deserve to live so are
they demand slaughter then is that what
they played in i don't know i've heard
like pro like pro choices say it's not a
you know it's not a life at this moment
in time it's no it's a lie it's a
collection of cells it's a fetus they've
used everything else to kind of like
dehumanize
what is within it fetus is a living
thing pay attention your biology lessons
95 of about 95 of biologists say that
life begins at conception
so even the science they say believe the
science until it doesn't support their
argument
yeah i mean even if we wasn't going with
that right even if we was defining life
at a heartbeat
you can detect that six weeks so if
we're defining a week six even if it
wasn't at conception
then
most women find out around that time or
maybe even later so
you know we still have to to to call it
what it is which is the truth is that is
considered a murder so i have a question
would you guys support a law that banned
abortion completely just yes or no going
around
uh
no no no
uh
no
okay no
[Music]
yes i know
you have to give one man
yeah yeah i have to choose one you have
to choose one then yeah i'll skip that
question
okay girl no
no no
pregnancies as abortion okay sorry with
the exception sorry with the exception
of extreme cases right okay then with
the exception of in the in the life of
the mother
if the mob is gonna die yeah
would you guys anyone would anyone
change their answer after i said that no
this is so complicated sorry so so hold
on let me just
so
you're saying
not to to not factor in that
i'm saying if the mother's life
is in danger she can get an abortion
outside of that no yeah i think i think
that's the only reason
that's the only reason i said no
personally is because there is those
exceptions so i would say it has to be
heavily regulated i'm talking about
heavily regulated is fine because we
heavily regulate a lot of things
when it comes to the medical um sector
so heavily regulated but i wouldn't say
get rid of it completely because in
those situations it does
you know wouldn't it force people to
make better decisions
yeah i mean like so if there was a law
it would actually force people to make
better sexual decisions